foreign
[Music]
and welcome to today's webinar boost
microbial detection sensitivity with
unbiased human host DNA and RNA
depletion
I am Kaylee Bach of lab roots and I'll
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by labroots and brought to you
by jumpcode genomics to learn more about
our sponsor please visit
jumpcodegenomics.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click Send we'll answer
as many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
I'd like to now welcome our speaker Dr
zennis George
senior scientists at gemco genomics
zenis you may now begin your
presentation
hi my name is Dennis George and I am a
senior scientist here at Johnstone
genomics I am part of the r d team and
currently leading the development of
host depletion product portfolio my
major discussion today will be on how to
Leverage The Power of jamco genomic
products to boost microbial detection
with unbiased human host DNA and RNA
depletion
I'll be sharing with you some of the
exciting results on the newly developed
host depletion product
and also touch on some of the other
applications of jamco genomics
Technology
so let's take a look at today's learning
objectives at the end of this webinar we
will understand how an unbiased
depletion method gives you the ability
to maximize microbial genome coverage
and get higher taxonomic resolution
we will also learn how to leverage
crispr-based depletion
to cut unwanted human whose molecules
from your next Generation sequencing
libraries before sequencing
and I will show us how we have applied
crispr-based depletion to characterize
microbial populations and their impacts
on human health
so the question we might have is why is
John good depletion kit well the answer
is simple and it is just that the vast
majority of molecules sequenced in many
NGS applications are uninformative
this uninformative molecules are found
in single cell data oncology sequencing
data infectious disease sequencing data
an inherited disease sequencing there as
well
and when you have an NGS data set with
vast amount of information on
informative data
what you are able to detect is limited
and the cost of sequencing to the depth
that could increase the detection level
could be unbearable so using jump code
products to remove uninformative
molecules before going into sequencing
enhance your detection sensitivity at a
lower cost
generalized workflow of crispr clean
technology where in this case the cas9
guide RNA complex
is used in depleting the uninformative
libraries that is the purple color lines
living intact the informative libraries
which are the blue color lines
our technology slot easily into various
NGS workflows
and note that the depletion workflow I'm
showing here is done on an already
constructed libraries but you can also
apply our technology before going into
live reconstruction
here I'm listing out some of the Chris
buckling product portfolio and they are
starting from the top left we have
crispr clean stranded total RNA prep
with ribosomal RNA dictation
this product is used in removing human
mouse and rat ribosomal RNA from rnsic
there
we also have crispr clean stranded total
RNA prep
with ribosomal RNA depletion this
product is used in removing human Mouse
right and also pan bacteria ribosomal
RNA from rna6 there with mixed human and
bacterial cells
another product that we have is Chris
buckling single cell RNA boost kit
which is used in removing about 50 of
sequences not used in cell typed
identification by single cell
determination software this product is
developed to enhance determination of
single cell population in 10x chromium
Library prep
and recently we have added another very
important product to the product
portfolio and that is the all-new host
depletion kit for human microbiome
studies since this is a new product I
will dive a little bit deeper into the
processes behind this exciting product
and the new possibilities that it
affords researchers interested in
unraveling the impact of microbiome on
human health
now let's take a quick look at the human
microbiome and from head to toe the
human body have us different species of
microbes regarded as microflorine
microflora could be commensal in which
case it's neither harmful nor beneficial
it could also be a mutualistic
relationship we have both human and the
microbes benefit
from their coexistence under normal
Circumstance the presence of microbe is
not of Health concern but we now know
that depending on the abundance and
variety of the microbial population at a
given location in or on the human body
they could be of great impact
the human heart
because of this studying the human
microbiome is of importance
and to study the human microbiome you
have to collect the sample from the side
of Interest
and as you can see from the table here
collecting an oral sample means that the
sample you are looking at has human host
material at roughly between 50 to 96
similar trend is also observed in many
other possible sites on the human body
like the skin nozzle and vaginal samples
where human content could be greater
than 95 percent
so the problem is that human derived
samples like vaginal nasal saliva and
blood have high host background that
limits detection of microbial population
especially the low biomass ones
to characterize the microbial contents
in microbiome samples researchers use
16a sequencing but this is hypothesis
driven and can only identify
non-microbes effectively incapable of
discovering new microbes
current solution used in removing human
host DNA capitalizes on the fact that
human cells are without cell wall while
on the other hand most microbes have
cell wall so this method uses chemicals
to light human cells which exposes the
human DNA which is then removed using
enzymes
leaving behind the theft lies microbial
cells
the microbial cells are then lies and
the DNA purified for microbial
characterization
the problem with this method is that
some
very important sexually transmitted
microbes such as microplasma is without
cell wall and will inadvertently utilize
and remove alongside human DNA
another problem with this method is that
should there be any extracellular micro
microbial DNA in the sample
then that will be removed alongside
human DNA and the microbial DNA
information will be lost
this method recommends fresh sample
since phrase four Cycles affect
microbial cell Integrity we know that
having free sample is not always
possible
which makes the demand for Freight
sample unrealistic
and overall this method has been shown
to bias towards gram-positive bacteria
which makes sense because the cell wall
of gram-negative bacteria is weaker than
that of gram-positive bacteria and could
be lies and remove alongside human
content
because of the limitation and bias it
reduced by current host depletion method
jump code has come up with a host
depletion method that is not driven by
hypothesis and is without any noticeable
bias in microbial content
characterization
so I will now be walking us through jump
code solution to removing High host
content from microbiome sample
this is a single day workflow that can
easily be applied to extracted total DNA
from microbiome samples looking at the
flowchart to the left after total Diana
extraction the DNA is quality checked
and size selected for fragments that are
15 KB and above
once that DNA is of this fragment range
the junk code protocol can be started
with DNA amounts of between 50 nanogram
to a thousand nanogram
the protocol starts with repairing and
blocking the ends of the DNA followed by
cleanup to remove enzyme and buffers at
this stage the DNA is ready to be
treated with crispr cas9 complex with
custom guide RNA
the crispr cas9 guide RNA treatment is
followed by cleanup step where enzyme
and buffers are also removed at this
stage the human whose DNA content have
been significantly removed and the DNS
sample can be used to make
NGS libraries using a library prep kit
of choice
we have successfully used illuminized
DNA Library prep kit for this purpose
so with jump cut solution you can
achieve unbiased view of the human
microbiome because our method uses
specific crispr mediated depletion of
the human DNA
you will also achieve improved microbial
genome coverage previously obscured by
human DNA you will increase detection
sensitivity of low abundant microbial
species
and this is a single day workflow
that can easily be applied the extracted
total DNA from microbiome sample
now I will be showing us some of the
results we have generated using our jump
code host depletion method to remove
human DNA content from contrived sample
and clinical saliva and vaginal swap
samples
where we observe an improved microbial
genome coverage previously obscured by
human DNA
now let's take a look at the bar charts
to the left
on the y-axis we have percent depletion
of our Target site and the x-axis
represents the samples tested
here our Target was
atrobacter lattice which is aloe
elements of which there are over 1
million copies spread throughout the
human genome and allo element is about
300 space in line
here we observe that we were successful
in removing approximately 99 of aloe
elements from both samples represented
here
I will not be showing us the read
reallocation metrics from our contrive
sample experiment to the left is a graph
of rates aligned to
human enzymogenomes before and after
depletion here the y-axis is percent
rate aligned to Human
enzymomicrobial Genome and untreated and
jumpers crispycline treated samples the
x-axis represents the samples tested the
first bar to the left is the untreated
sample and has 99.25 percent of rates
aligned to Human Genome why 0.75 percent
of rates are aligned to zymo microbial
genome this is followed by jump coat
screen sparkling treated replicate 1
which noun has
88.81 percent of rates aligned to Human
Genome while 11.19 of rates are aligned
to zymo microbial genome
the third bar graph starting from the
left is replicate number two of John
code's respect and treated sample which
noun has 88.48 percent of rate aligned
to Human Genome while 11.52 percent of
rates are aligned to zymo microbial
genome
to the right is bar chart showing how
the rates align to the 10 zymo microbial
genomes are redistributed to each
species within the community in
replicate number one as can be seen
there is greater than 13-fold increase
in rates aligned to each species and
this increase is without any obvious
bias even though this community compress
of species with differences in GC
content genome size and Gram stain
status
the redistribution of replicate number
two was similar to that of replicate 1
presented here
here to the right we have a graph
showing the breadth of coverage on the
y-axis and the number of rates on the
x-axis
for smaller genome within the zymo
community like staphylococcus and
lactobacillus
you can actually cover more than 90 of
the entire genome even at 10 million
rates and for the community members with
larger genome like saccharomyces and
cryptococcus you still notice an
increased breadth of coverage that will
definitely boost the accuracy of
detection
so we have seen how John good human DNA
depletion kit is effective in depleting
Human Genome without introducing any
obvious bias as can be seen with design
one microbial for change
now we want to look at how our jump good
host depletion kit performs complete
existing host depletion kit using actual
clinical sample which was saliva sample
in this case
we conducted an experiment to check how
our jump code human DNA depletion kit
compared to other host depression kits
out there the initial competitive
testing was between jungle human DNA
depletion kit and more zymolysis basic
five kit
with the mozzyme Molasses basis 5 kit
you have the option of using a DNA
extraction kit of choice to extract the
microbial DNA after depleting the human
genome
to make sure that there was no bias
introduced by DNA extraction method
after the depletion of human genome from
the saliva sample using more than basic
microbial DNA was extracted using
cardigan Blood and Tissue total DNA
extraction kit which is the same DNA
extraction kit that was used for the
sample treated with jump code genomic
human DNA depletion kit
the same lot of clinical sample
which was saliva in this case were
tested using the two host depletion
methods from the results
we noticed that
Jungkook human DNA depletion kit are
performed more than basic 5. because
junk code has the least impact on
microbial composition
jump code also has higher species counts
correlation between untreated and
depleted samples and marzime license
method requires fresh sample
here we are looking at the correlation
graphs generated using sequencing Rich
data from the samples that were tested
on the y-axis is the reads the species
in samples treated with either jump code
host depletion kit which is to the left
the graph to the left or more than
molasses basic 5 which is the graph to
the right the x-axis represent the reads
per species in untreated samples we
notice a high level of correlation with
the jump code hose depletion kit with an
r squared of 0.96 on the other hand the
mozzyme Molasses basic 5 gave an r
squared of 0.86
this Matrix for that shows that jump
code human DNA depletion kit are
performed morezide more or less is basic
5 kits
now let's take a look at how using John
code human DNA depletion kit to deplete
Human Genome in saliva and vaginal
samples have increased detection
sensitivity for low abundant microbial
species
here to the left is bar graph showing
rate real location in untreated and jump
code human DNA depletion kit treated
vaginal sample
for the bar graph to the left the y-axis
represents the number of reads allocated
to each kingdom while the x-axis
represent the different samples
and to the right is a bar graph of four
change on the y-axis and the sample
represented on the x-axis
notice that in the untreated sample on
the bar graph to the left
5.17 percent of the rates is allocated
to microbial species
but with the vaginal sample in which
human genome contents was depleted using
jump code human DNA depletion kits the
reads relocated to microbial species
jumped 3.7 fold to 19.02 percent and
this increase
as we will see next
resulted in detection of more microbial
species in samples where Human Genome
was depleted using junk code human DNA
depletion kit
here to the left we are looking at bar
graphs with the number of bacterial
species with read counts of 10 or more
on the y-axis while the x-axis represent
different samples
notice that in the untreated sample on
the bar graph to the left there are 10
bacterial species with 10 or more Roots
but with the vaginal sample in which
human genome content was depleted using
junk code human DNA depletion kit the
number of bacterial species with 10 or
more Rich shoots up to 46
which is more than four-fold increase
and the very interesting thing is that
all of the 10 species in the untreated
samples are among the 46 patients
detected in the jump good human DNA
depleted kit treated sample this is
Illustrated in the Venn diagram to the
right
here we are looking at results from
saliva sample experiment and to the left
we have bar graphs with the number of
bacterial species having rate count of
10 or more on the y-axis while the
x-axis represent a different samples
tested
notice that in both sample number one
and Sample number two the untreated
samples consistently have lower number
of bacterial species when compared to
the saliva samples in which human genome
content was depleted using jump code
human DNA depletion kit and the
interesting thing is that after
depletion for sample number one you
detect 29 more bacterial species
while sample number two you detect 32
more bacterial species after depletion
with jump code human DNA depletion kit
and for each sample the bacterial
species with 10 or more reads in the
untreated sample are a subset of the
species detected in the jump good human
DNA depletion kit treated sample this is
Illustrated in the Venn diagram to the
right
so we jump good human depletion kit you
can do more at lower cost boosting your
microbial Rich content to more than
three times
resulting in the detection of more than
29 bacterial species and all these
benefits achieved in a one-day workflow
additionally
with jump good human DNA depletion kit
you characterize your sample with
confidence because from all what we've
seen jump could human DNA depletion kit
does not introduce any noticeable bias
and this applies to fresh and frozen
samples
so reach out to our sales team at cells
jumpcodegenomics.com and get your Early
Access kit and begin to reap the
benefits of jump code human DNA
depletion kit these benefits will
include unbiased view of human
microbiome because our method uses
specific crispr mediated depletion of
the human DNA
you will also achieve improved microbial
genome coverage previously or skilled by
human DNA you increase detection
sensitivity
of low abundant microbial species
and this is easily done in a single day
workflow and can be applied
to extract it to the DNA from microbiome
sample be it frozen or fresh samples
now before I end I wanted to introduce
you to another very exciting application
of junk code crispr clean technology
which we are working on
so
currently we have a crispr clean plus
product
which performs well in removing human
and bacterial ribosomal RNA from RNA
sign there but in this experiment we
tested the depletion rate using the
crispr Clean Plus guide set
and on top of that we added additional
guide set designated as gs1 and GS2 and
this amount to approximately 1.3 million
guys in the reaction
and after we perform this experiment the
depletion rate was phenomenal
in this experiment we use contrive
sample which consists of 50 human total
RNA fifty percent zymo Community
standard RNA and we also spike in at
0.001 percent a size group to RNA in
this experiment there was one control
where there was no jump code crispr
clean treatment
and there was also a sample set in which
we only trade with the crispr Clean Plus
guide set only
and it fits it was the one that we
treated with the crispr Clean Plus guide
set and also in addition to that we
added the gs1 and the GS2 guide set in
the end we are looking at for how the
coverage of SAS group 2 genome
which was not targeted by any of the
guide sets will increase after the
depletion of the human and the bacterial
RNA
the y-axis on the bar graph is the depth
of coverage of SAS Cove 2 while the
x-axis represents the different samples
notice that the untreated control
sample size group 2 has a depth of
coverage of 0.6 X
and with the sample treated using only
the crispr clean guide set only you
notice that the depth of coverage is now
5.33 X
and then when you treat the sample with
a cocktail of the crisper clean guys set
alongside the gs1 and the GS2 guide set
the depth of coverage for saskoff 2
jumps to a whopping 17.5 X which
translates to a 26 volt increase
this was a very exciting outcome and we
will be building up on this to make sure
that we have the tools to continue to
fight the current pandemic while
preparing for uh events of any new
pandemic
here is a graphical representation of
the size curve to genome coverage
the y-axis is the depth of coverage
while the x-axis represents the 29 KB
Sales Group 2 genome the blue plot is
the control while the purple plot is
that of the contrive sample that was
treated with a cocktail of the crispr
Clean Plus guide set plus the gs1 and
the GS2 guide sets
so you can see why I'm excited about the
future of crisper clean technology and
you have lots of options in our toolbox
to enhance your research
I know this is a lot of information but
I'm definitely excited and I will stop
here so I can take your questions thank
you
great well thank you Zenith for your
informative presentation
we will now start the live q a portion
of the webinar if you have a question
you'd like to ask please do so now just
click on the ask a question box located
on the far left of your screen we'll
answer as many of your questions as we
have time for
all right so let's get started our first
question here asks what steps were taken
to ensure no microbial sequences were
depleted
very good question thanks for that
um our job uh genomic uh
genomic pipeline uses a very specific
guide design pipeline in which the
Target that we were using in this case
was Aloo sequence which is primate
specific and we also make sure that
during the guide design we filter it
through pathogens website and also
any other microbial website and through
all of those filtering we in the end
make sure that no other micro is
targeted we are just like specifically
targeting the human genome so we did all
the filtering through our specific
pipeline to make sure that there is no
off Target effect
great thank you I have another question
for you here and this one asks will this
protocol work with archive samples
yes very good question as well and I
think that is where the strength of uh
the jump code host depletion product
comes in because most uh products out
there that are doing this require that
you have fresh samples jump code doesn't
require your fresh sample because we
know it is difficult to actually get
fresh samples
so with jump code genomic host depletion
protocol you don't need fresh samples
you extract your sample grab total DNA
from your sample
and then you can be sure that John could
depletion protocol will only remove the
human and then leave your microbial DNA
intact
great
next question here asks the longest
fragment lengths in my samples are about
10 KB do I still need to do size
selection prior to your protocol
good question so um the current uh
version of our product
still requires even though your sample
is of 10 KB we still require that you
size select for the 15 KB plus so that
you will get the full benefit of the
depletion it's not that 10 KB average
size would not still deplete you will
still deplete but you won't have as good
depletion as you would with a 15 KB plus
so yes we still do recommend at this
stage that your size select for 15 KB
Plus
wait
but a few more questions in the queue
here I want to remind our audience that
if they do have any more questions
please submit them now we've still got
some time here so this next question
asks how is the depletion strategy
different from other host depletion
methods
yes again a very good question we are
very unique in what we do and this is
quite different so now if you look at
other methods uh because human cells do
have uh doesn't have cell wall but most
microbial organisms do have cell wall so
other methods do uh capitalize on that
and then they will easily lies the human
cell with easy chemicals and then
when that is done the DNA is exposed and
then it's removed using enzymes this
process use the microbial cells intact
then
you would remove that remove the humans
uh then go in analyze the microbial
cells and that is how it works but now
we know that something uh microbes like
micro plasma they don't have cell wall
but there are also microbes so those
microbes will be removed so we are
different
in the sense that
you will not have to worry about if your
microbe has cell wall or not so you can
grab everything as long as they are in
there in the end you will only remove
the human uh cell the human genome from
your sample and there is also uh the
problem of when you see uh even the
microbe have cell wall something like uh
gram-positive and gram-negative they
have different levels of the cell wall
so gram-negative will have a weaker cell
wall than a gram positive one so with
that you can also have a system in which
those other methods would introduce by
us because they would also easily when
you freestyle your sample those weaker
cell walls will break open and then you
will remove your microbial
DNA as well so as is very unique in that
you don't need to worry yourself about
your sample being fresh or you having
microbial DNA in so solution without
having intact cells of your microbes so
we are unique in that we don't require
free samples and we also work with total
DNA
wonderful thank you
next question here asks does this
depletion strategy bias toward
gram-positive or grand negative bacteria
very good question so we do not observe
any obvious bias from the presentation
you saw that the zymo microbial
community that we were looking at have
different GC contents have gram-positive
and grab negative microbes in there and
we did not see any bias in the boosting
of each of those microbes but we know
that other methods do bias because they
use selective license which we know is
not always perfect so our method doesn't
bias towards Grant positive bacteria
well thank you Zenith we're going to go
ahead and wrap up here do you have any
final comments for our audience
yes so uh thanks uh Kelly for organizing
this it is quite exciting and uh I would
thank you guys so much for joining today
and again if you have any questions we
are always ready to answer your question
and I think this is a very exciting
product that uh you want to test and see
it for yourself how you would boost your
Discovery and I would say again thank
you so much for your time
thank you all right well thank you one
more time zennis for your time today and
your important research we would also
like to thank Lab Rats and our sponsor
jump code genomics for underwriting
today's educational webcast
and before we go I'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions questions we
did not have time for today and those
submitted during the on-demand period
will be addressed by the speaker via the
contact information you provided at the
time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand and
labyrinths will alert you via email when
it's available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event
until next time take care everyone
goodbye